foreign
[Music]
hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
new people dream about success from a
young age we see the covers of magazines
featuring young entrepreneurs those who
thought different defied the status quo
and decided to embark on a journey that
led them to massive wealth and success
we all know these stories but sometimes
when someone tries to achieve success by
any means necessary it can go very wrong
such is the story of Charlie Javis
on the surface everything seemed
Flawless millions of dollars in funding
from JP Morgan a spot on the prestigious
Forbes 30 under 30 list and support from
industry Titans like a polo CEO Mark
Rowan
but lurking behind this polished facade
was a network of lies to seat and
flagrant exaggerations for a decade
Charlie carefully crafted an image that
deflected nearly all controversies
but as we've seen previously on this
channel her precious House of Cards
eventually Came Crashing Down could be
facing up to 100 years in prison accused
of defrauding JP Morgan Chase out of
millions Charlie Javis she was a hot
shot in the startup World student scam
students but scammed the bank so who was
she and how did she manage to fool and
defraud one of the biggest banks in the
world
is the story of Charlie Javis
[Music]
Charlie's entrepreneurial aspirations
seems to have taken root in her teenage
years she grew up in an affluent New
York family attending a well-known
french-american private school in New
York the idea for her first Venture came
while she was still in high school in a
story strangely mirroring Elizabeth
Holmes she got her first idea after a
trip overseas for Charlie Javas the
destination was Thailand and when she
returned she had the idea to start a
microfinance product
during her visit she recognized that
people in developing nations lacked
access to credit
her solution was to have a service that
offered small low interest and secure
loans to those who are underprivileged
the result was her non-profit called
pover up it worked as an online platform
that used microfinance for social good
to quote and poverty with the click of a
mouse it would work by harnessing small
student contributions to make loans
possible but as we'll later see even in
this all was not as it seems
After High School Charlie pursued a
finance and law undergraduate degree at
Wharton her Venture made headlines
Landing her a feature in ink magazine
they called her idea one of the coolest
College startups
around the same time fast company listed
her as one of 100 of the most creative
people this was the first time she was
able to create media attention as it
would turn out this would be the most
important skill that she had
the recognition caught the eye of the
Peter Thiel Foundation they were
offering students one hundred thousand
dollars to leave college and chase their
entrepreneurial dreams
however according to a cover-up tumbler
post Charlie withdrew from the
competition choosing to stay in school
despite missing out on a hundred
thousand dollars the scholarship bid
earned her significant media attention
way more than before
following graduation Javas began
exploring New Market gaps that required
addressing
following several business plan
revisions she finally discovered the
free application for federal student aid
or FAFSA and this is what it is each
year the federal student aid office
distributes over 249 billion dollars in
federal aid to 13 million students the
thing is there's a major issue with it
the application process is notoriously
difficult causing students to leave
billions of dollars unclaimed each year
determined to assist students she
devised a solution that could simplify
the whole process to an application of
just five minutes or less
it's totally free that's really
important to us for all students to
benefit from so a student takes a
picture of their tax returns then we do
all the tax math for you so no math
errors that can put you into very
complicated verification very simple
language we take a flow that might take
hours with the federal government and
most students take four minutes with us
so that's more or less how it works you
see how much you're eligible for then
you can go to school feel confident see
what your bill is and then figure out
the Gap to help you
this was the core idea of what she would
call Frank as she described quote Frank
kind of represented that as a name
because it just meant honest using her
status and connections that she'd gained
from meter exposure she was easily able
to find financing for her project in
just a few years Frank had raised more
than 20 million dollars in funding and
accumulated over 300 000 users
on paper the company looked like a
massive success with Javis seizing every
opportunity to promote herself as an
up-and-coming star of the business world
she reflected her thoughts to Insider in
2021 quote I built a business and raised
funds out of college turning down a
finance job even though I was told I
would fail because I didn't have
business experience
but soon major red flags began to appear
in 2017 the Department of Education
issued a cease and assist letter the
reason Frank may be misleading students
into thinking that it's associated with
the government's official website
following the incident the company
changed its marketing to clarify that it
had no affiliation with the US
government but this was just the
beginning of the problems
in December of 2017 Javas wrote an
opinion piece for the New York Times it
was supposed to be on quote the eight
most confusing things about FAFSA the
thing was the article later had to
include a significant correction stating
that there were multiple inaccuracies
about the aid process
now just think to yourself how was the
CEO of a company that specializes in
this exact field able to get so many
things wrong it's not a good look
the general public didn't pay much
attention though because Javas was on a
media tour she frequently appeared on
articles and podcasts so much so that it
culminated in her inclusion on the
Forbes prestigious 30 under 30 list in
[Music]
by 2021 Javas had begun exploring the
possibility of selling her Venture by
the start of summer the now famous
startup founder was able to secure a
meeting with JP Morgan eager to expand
their presence in the rapidly growing
niche of Student Financial products JP
Morgan saw Charlie javis's Company Frank
as a great way to increase market share
and secure talent to help them grow in
that sector during the meetings Javas
held nothing back and she pitched her
company as quote an acquisition machine
amassing over 4.5 million customers in
just four years
she also claimed that her company knew
quote more about their students than any
lender college or employer
the pitch was a success after a few
meetings she managed to convince JP
Morgan to purchase her company for 175
million dollars it was an amazing Payday
for Charlie
though there was one thing remaining the
bank had to do due diligence and one of
the first items on JP Morgan's due
diligence list to verify those 4.25
million customers that Charlie said she
had amassed at this point it's important
to remember that the bulk of the
company's price had to do with the
quality of their customer base
the higher the number the higher the
price tag that JP Morgan would be
willing to pay
something peculiar happened
Charlie refused to provide the list she
said privacy concerns but there was
another reason for this she was hiding
something the fact was in reality there
weren't 4 million users but fewer than
three hundred thousand
[Music]
when July 2021 arrived Charlie needed to
present the data for the deal to proceed
she was at a Crossroads now should she
disclose the actual figures and risk
losing a very profitable deal or
fabricate the numbers to guarantee the
acquisition
you see Charlie was worried because
before JP Morgan there was another
bidder for the company but after they
saw the real numbers they withdrew the
negotiations fearing the loss of another
potential buyer she opted to falsify the
data hoping she could pull it off
according to legal documents quote Javas
chose each time to lie and time and
again she layered fraud upon fraud to
deceive JP Morgan
Javas needed to figure something out and
quickly how was she going to get a
customer database with more than 4
million customer emails this is where
her Chief growth officer Olivia Amar
comes into the picture initially Amar
approached the company's top engineer to
create the fake account but the engineer
smelt a rat and he questioned the
legality of the request
Javas assured him that quote no one will
end up in an orange jumpsuit but the
engineer knew better and he ultimately
refused having no other option Charlie
had a backup she knew a guy a professor
in New York who specialized in quote
Creative Solutions for data problems she
would reach out to him for help
with the professor's assistants they
were able to create over 4 million fake
accounts by using an algorithm the
algorithm created new fake customer
information based on real profiles
after some tinkering they scrape
together a list they held their breath
and sent it off to JP Morgan
surprisingly or unsurprisingly the
banking giant bought it
as a thank you Javas paid the professor
eighteen thousand dollars for his
efforts
and now they just had to wait for their
payday but before that they needed to
cover their tracks Charlie ordered the
destruction of the fake customer list
within minutes of a third party
completing their analysis Amar spent an
additional 105 000 acquiring a separate
data set of 4.5 million students this
was a contingency plan just in case the
other data set failed
once the deal closed Javas received 10
million dollars in compensation and was
eligible for an additional 20 million
retention bonus as a managing director
at JP Morgan Amar became an executive
director and received 5 million as well
as a 3 million retention bonus
around that time Charlie went on to
social media to boast that quote it's
not every day that an entrepreneur gets
her fairy tale new beginning not ending
however this illusion of Glory ended
almost as quickly as it began
a couple of months later JP Morgan was
busy integrating Charlie's company and
team into their operations they wanted
to start utilizing that fast customer
base that they acquired in the process
the dispatched advertisement emails to
400 000 Franc customers and here it was
immediately clear that something was
horribly wrong
a mere 20 of emails were even delivered
and an even more minuscule one percent
were opened investigating deeper JP
Morgan discovered the email exchange
with the corrupt University professor
and they were seeing red
both Amar and Javis would be suspended
from their JP Morgan roles and in
December of 2022 JP Morgan filed charges
against them Javas had the goal to
retaliate and counter Sue she argued
that her termination was not just you
know what else isn't just faking your
entire business
unfortunately for her the court found
the evidence against her to be
compelling and in April 2023 she was
found guilty on four separate counts of
having quote falsely and dramatically
inflated Frank's customer numbers and
quote fraudulently induced JP Morgan to
acquire her company
[Music]
uh now to a high profile fraud case
that's uh literally happening in front
of us in real time the 31 year old
accused of quote falsely and
dramatically inflating the number of
customers that the company had in the
scheme to fraudulently induce JP Morgan
to acquire the startup in 2021 she stood
to gain more than 45 million dollars
from the alleged deception in January
JPMorgan CEO Jamie dimon called the
acquisition of Frank a quote huge
mistake there's a lot of people around a
transaction of these of this size and
not to have any idea that the numbers uh
aren't exactly what uh is being said
kind of go back to FTS you know it's
just shocking that she thought she could
just get away with faking the numbers
and lying taking home the pay packet and
expecting JP Morgan just to not look
deeper
if we dig deeper into Charlie's history
we begin to see the real picture and
it's a real doozy
as it turns out her squeaky clean image
was just an illusion as a person
familiar with her would later remark
quote this is exactly what she had been
doing what she had been doing all along
and now she has gotten caught for it
tracing things back to her college Years
remember her first Venture cover up the
micro lending platform for developing
countries well it was never officially
registered as any type of company there
are no records of its existence and this
is despite her bold claims of customers
and partnership deals some of those
Partners have even come out and said no
we don't know who this person is we've
never done a deal with povera or Charlie
Javas despite telling Wharton magazine
in 2013 that pover-up raised three
hundred thousand dollars from friends or
family a former board member confirmed
it didn't distribute a single loan
and remember the Peter Thiel scholarship
that she supposedly turned down well
Michael Gibson who oversaw the grants
stated in a Forbes article quote she was
never offered a fellowship and it
bothers me that she is going around
saying that because of her personality
we didn't trust that she could get
started in a real way
reportedly her team cheated during a
scavenger hunt challenge for the
scholarship trials Gibson commented
quote the funny thing is cheating in a
scavenger hunt is a pretty small thing
but it's weird now she's being accused
of something on a much greater grander
scale it's almost like too much on the
nose he also recalled that one reason
for her rejection from the program was
that she presented her Venture as
ongoing when in reality there was
nothing to show for it of course as was
seen already
despite all these disasters she would
move on to her next project Frank and
secure 10 million dollars in funding
but this company was also a mess
initially it was a job search website
that connected young workers with job
opportunities via text message then it
was a credit score website and finally
it helps students with Aid programs
according to insiders it was a very
Rocky start allegedly the Venture ran
out of money leading Javas to stop
paying her employees and refused to
provide promised Equity bonuses this led
to a lawsuit but this disaster didn't
matter because Javas was a marketing
genius she could rewrite her own
narrative when she would retell the
story she omitted the lawsuit she said
the layoffs were the most difficult time
in her life
so we know that Javis does seem to
manipulate and lie but by the time she
launched Frank she'd gone Bonkers a
person present at the first investor
meeting said that Javis promoted the
product by claiming that they had
thousands of sign ups when they had none
quote we'd all start looking at each
other like this is insanity you can't be
saying these things some of the things
that were being said were just
inexcusably inaccurate
when those same people ended up
confronting her about it Javas would
State quote listen these old people
don't understand this is how it works
you fake it till you make it in one of
her appearances on a podcast she stated
that quote being a Founder I'm obviously
skewed towards being overly optimistic
and sometimes that works to your
advantage sometimes it doesn't and there
were definitely times where I painted a
Rosier picture than things truly were
regarding the internal atmosphere of the
company from her previous mismanagement
experiences testimonies from employees
painted a picture of misery with
management solely focusing on user-based
growth and neglecting all other concerns
as it stands Charlie javis's story
emerges as yet another cautionary tale
drawing parallels with the cases of
Elizabeth Holmes and Sam Beckman freed
in each of these three scenarios their
marketing prowess significantly outshone
their actual management abilities Javas
was marketed as a genius she lied and
faked her way to the top but bit off
more than she could chew when she tried
to scam J.P Morgan and it came back to
bite her in a big way
this is also a vivid reminder of how the
fake it till you make it mentality can
backfire and rapidly on a wider macro
scale this kind of tells us something as
well usually during boom times and
prosperous times unethical Behavior can
easily be overlooked Tech investors are
eagerly jumping on every opportunity
because if they don't they're going to
miss out on the next big thing but when
the economic tide turns and sober
reality returns many are left stranded
and this is precisely the current
sentiment
the Forbes 30 under 30 list has been
widely ridiculed for showcasing some of
the Decades most notorious fraudsters on
its magazine covers
however the selections themselves may
not be the issue as you know if you've
watched my videos since 2008 until very
recently we have been living in a fake
macroeconomic environment supported by
low interest rates and easy money now
add social media into the mix where
reality and fiction blur and you have a
recipe for individuals that want to take
advantage of the times and craft
narratives for their own fake success so
that is the story of Charlie Javas the
woman who flew too close to the sun
which was JP Morgan
for me scammers and fraudsters have
always been out there but there's
something about the millennial
generation that just seems to be on a
grander scale and much more Brazen if
you've got any thoughts on why I'd be
interested to hear that's just my
opinion though and I'm a millennial
myself so I'm not throwing any shade
all right so thanks for watching hope
you did enjoy that if you did feel free
to look around on the channel there's
plenty of interesting stuff on here on
science technology and business
my name is Togo and you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll catch you again
soon for the next episode cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
stop trying
it's me thinking